all right well since it is thursday you
do know what that means it's time to
break down all things survivor 42. yes
but before we get to the messy tribal
council we have to talk about danielle
yeah so back day one he was the guy who
dislocated his shoulder and since then
he has yet to compete in a swimming
challenge so
it it was interesting to see how
surprised
i say bhatti tribe uh mates uh to see
him spear fishing
wait so he can't complete his challenges
but he can go literally spearfishing
that's what i'm confused about
daniel's arm has been dislocated since
day one but yet today he's in the ocean
fishing
[Music]
what hey mike chanel
you can't compete in swimming challenges
but he can go swimming for fish
you can't swim at a challenge but you're
gonna go into open water with a spear
and you're
daniel says he has a stand of all the
swimming challenges because he can't
swim
you see how far away that coral reef is
it's beautiful out there
tons of fish so you're saying your aim
sucks yes my aim sucks i can't close a
few times you had there a long time too
it's really hard to swim out there
i found it rather relaxing and
meditating
yes and now of course we are joined with
our special survivor correspondent
season 41 winner erica casupinen hello
erica hi roz and sangeeta it's always
great to be back and i'm happy to chat
all things survivor okay first let's
recap all things daniel i mean the fact
that he kept sitting out in challenges
and then he went spear fishing he
doesn't even know how to swim apparently
he does so what do you think of his game
i think that anything you do in survivor
could be something good or something bad
for you i think that daniel having this
dislocated shoulder and going fishing
right i think it's more than just
fishing i think that it's still daniel
kind of saying one thing and then doing
something different and it just kind of
casts this light on him that we can't
always rely on him
that's right now last night we also got
to witness another nail biter of an
immunity challenge that ended up sending
vanti tribe to tribal council and man
was it messy yeah erica i'm actually
kind of scared of chanel
the way she played her game at the end
she's a shark i mean she's the one who
voted for mike why do you think she did
that i don't think it was a great game
play what are your thoughts on it i mean
i have a lot of thoughts on this one
yeah a lot of people online are talking
about this one i think that there's one
camp of people who are looking at it
saying that it's a strategic move if you
look at it logically she's setting up
insurance for herself in case daniel
uses his shot in the dark there's
another camp of people who are seeing
this as if chanel knew what was going on
around camp knew where the votes were
lying if she if she was able to socially
get that information then she wouldn't
need to do that she would be over
playing so where do i stand
i think that i don't have enough
information to really know i know that
through being out there there are so
many levels to it we don't know what
chanel knew before tribal council so i
think that i just
we're just seeing a peanut mike is gonna
be upset though he's not gonna be happy
that's the thing i think that that's
going to be a consequence of that big
one and after it was all said and done
daniel was the one who got his torch
snuffed
i mean i think daniel's mess has finally
caught up with him he was entertaining
to watch i talked to him this afternoon
and he actually was very aware that he
made a lot of mistakes so here's what he
had to say about last night's tribal
council
when you were going into tribal council
where did you think all of the votes
were going to fall
um so
i thought that chanel would go home
i thought mike was voting chanel i was
voting chanel
um i'm trying to remember
i thought
mike high and me were voting chanel i
thought there was a chance that lydia
would vote for me
um just in case you know chanel played
her shot in the dark and also like lydia
was never gonna not vote for me after
that cluster
um
and chanel i just thought was gonna vote
for me um so i thought i was talk again
i had that combo with hi
and i thought i was totally safe i
really did i thought i was totally safe
so i was blindsided but erica you've
never been voted out one day you might
and i'm telling you the best way to go
out
is a blind side why do you want to roll
a little dinky dice and then have a
thing like who can who wants that i got
the real survivor experience by getting
blindsided
you know what i'm okay with never
experiencing a survivor blindside but i
do appreciate that he's looking at this
positively ah sure okay erica
one of the conversations during tribal
council was talking about trust and how
important it is especially going from
this point on is it important
i think trust is important but hot take
i don't think trust is the most
important thing when i played there were
people who didn't trust me who voted
with me during the game they didn't
trust me and they voted for me at the
end and i think that trust is one
currency there's a lot of different
currencies on survivor and it's really
about knowing how to play with whatever
you have in the bank it's all about
lying raws it's all about listen i
support this you know me uh okay last
but certainly not least we gotta talk
about the sneak peek for next week's
episode the tribes are being shaken up
but not with emerge yeah looks like jeff
is throwing another curveball at the
castaways erica how much do you think
this is going to shake up the game what
are you predicting what will happen this
is crazy i mean it looks like they're
throwing another big twist at the
castaways as someone who experienced a
merge twist and it led to my most
miserable in my most memorable time in
my life i'm excited to see what's going
to happen but i think that vati is going
to be in a bit of a mess when they get
to the merge because they haven't been
able to vote together so i think that
they're going to be looking for new
allies which could be
which could lead to them either being at
the bottom or finding themselves in a
good position and i also think that
these amulet people of drea lindsey and
hai are going to be getting together and
we'll see who is going to shoot first so
basically i think whatever is happening
onwards is going to be a mess of fun to
watch i wonder where marianne's going to
end up i she's going to be talking about
it whatever it is